good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson said happy Monday knowing what
we know about our current leadership
class the one thing we could be
absolutely certain of is they always go
too far they always get over their skis
they just can't help themselves that's
who they are so in February when the
Russian military invaded Ukraine there
was always out there the chance that the
bite Administration would find a way to
turn what was a regional tragedy into
something bigger like an historical
Global catastrophe that was always
possible so even before Russian forces
entered the Ukraine the White House
promised us that would not happen quote
there is no intention or interest or
Desire by the president to send troops
to Ukraine that was the word from
Biden's publicist from the White House
she said the very same thing almost
identically the next month the month
after that she said it again quote Joe
Biden does not have the intention of
sending U.S troops to Ukraine jensaki
solemnly pledged to the nation why did
jensaki keep saying the same thing over
and over well because it wasn't true she
had to repeat it because it was a lie
that's how lying works it's not
believable so you have to say it again
and again and again if you wonder if
someone's lying count the times they
assert something
the more often they assert the less
likely this to be true but also when the
truth does come out and this weekend it
began to Joe Biden's top surrogate in
the Congress that would be Senator Chris
Coons of Delaware a former Biden intern
appeared on CBS News and said the
opposite of what the White House has
been telling us for months
Coons demanded that the Pentagon deploy
American troops to Ukraine to fight
Russian soldiers watch
in some public remarks this week you
said
the country needs to talk about when it
might be willing to send troops to
Ukraine if Vladimir Putin who has shown
us how brutal he can be is allowed to
just continue to Massacre civilians to
commit war crimes throughout Ukraine
without NATO without the West coming
more forcefully to his Aid I great I I
deeply worry that what's going to happen
next is that we will see Ukraine turn
into Syria the American people cannot
turn away from this tragedy in Ukraine I
think the history of the 21st century
turns on how fiercely we defend freedom
in Ukraine and that Putin will only stop
when we stop him
without the West coming more forcefully
to the aid of Ukraine so the Ukrainian
military has been trained by NATO it
uses American Arms in some cases being
led by Americans the Ukrainian
government is advised directly moment to
Moment by Americans or many Americans in
Ukraine right now doing that
so what Chris Coons is calling for is
land war with Russia
now that's not a small thing given that
once again Chris Coons is Joe Biden's
closest Ally in the Senate Chris Coons
is an unfailing and faithful spokesman
for the administration's policies
whatever those policies happen to be so
in Chris Coons calls for war with Russia
he does not do it accidentally and in
this case the White House has not
distanced itself from what Chris [ __ ]
said
oh why well because war with Russia is
the administration's actual policy
leaders of the democratic party want to
topple the Russian government by force
and affect regime change in Russia they
have wanted this since the day that
Hillary Clinton lost the 2016
presidential race we know this because
they've said so many many times
and the only reason the rest of us
missed it is because we didn't take them
seriously enough but we should have
a hot war with Vladimir Putin using
American troops is The Logical maybe
inevitable end stage of Russia gate so
the whole thing began with Hillary
Clinton complaining then the P tape and
now it's moving toward nuclear war
so what would that look like a hot war
with Russia how many Americans would die
during that war How likely is it to
escalate to nuclear conflict and if we
succeed if we remove Vladimir Putin from
Office who will replace him as the head
of Russia in charge of 6 000 nuclear
weapons those are some of the first
questions that jumped to mind when
warwith Russia is discussed
but the news reader on CBS who was
interviewing Chris Coons didn't bother
to ask any of those questions nor did
she asked the one thing you would need
to know if you were running a
functioning democracy which is how many
Americans how many voters actually want
war with Russia what percentage of the
American population believes Ukraine's
borders are worth dying for
that's a central question in a democracy
and it happens we know the answer
because CBS itself ran a poll on that
topic just a week ago and they asked
this question should the United States
send troops to Ukraine answer fully 75
of Americans said no the United States
should not send troops to Ukraine and
yet somehow the CBS news reader forgot
to mention any of this to Chris Coons
why well you know why because in
Washington what you think is irrelevant
our foreign policy matters of life and
death
decisions that destroy Nations
are made entirely by people with no skin
in the game people who face no
conceivable risk of injury people like
John Bolton and Max Boone Toria Newlin
your opinion doesn't factor into the
equation at any point
so if you bothered to ask American
citizens what they think if you cared
about democracy you would they'd likely
tell you that their borders are more
important to them than Ukraine's borders
are that makes sense because they're
Americans not ukrainians and if you ask
deeper you would find out that at the
very top of their concerns is not
Ukraine they feel Sympathy for the
people of Ukraine but they're not taking
up too much disk space brooding about
Ukraine moment to moment because they
have other things to worry about
starting with their own economy
especially the cost of food energy and
housing they're worried about these
things and they're right to be worried
at this point the United States is
looking at a grim economic picture
before you pull out that credit card
today beware if you don't pay it off in
full your interest rate is probably
about to jump the Federal Reserve the
nation's Central Bank is expected to
raise rates by a quarter point today as
it tries to throw cold water on runaway
inflation every time you go and Shop
every like a price of something has gone
up by so much it's insane every American
Shopper has seen it firsthand clothing
up six and a half percent food up eight
and a half percent electricity up nine
percent used cars up 41 and gasoline up
nearly a buck 50 from a year ago milk
flour sugar
um like cartons of oil like frying oil
that's been insane that's like tripled
in price so that's been crazy the
highest inflation in 40 years
highest inflation in 40 years those the
official numbers which of course bear no
resemblance to the day-to-day reality
everything is much more expensive and
that's especially true of the big things
the big things are the most expensive of
all and why is that simple the declining
power of U.S currency has created an
unprecedented asset bubble that means
investors around the world are rushing
to convert increasingly worthless US
Dollars into objects that might hold
value over time so anything tangible
costs a lot more a lot more than it did
a year ago there's no mystery in this
this is exactly what happens when you
pump too much money into an economy the
money becomes worth less
so where is this going how is it going
to unfold nobody believes the interest
rate Rises we're seeing will get
inflation under control quickly so what
happens well at some point consumers
will begin to run out of cash to spend
assets will become too expensive to buy
and the average person will have less
money to buy them
at the same time that prices are rising
so are taxes property taxes are rising
in many places in tandem with the real
estate bubble so even if you didn't buy
a new house you will suffer because of
that
state income taxes have risen
dramatically in places like New York
so they're getting it from both ends and
that means that some people maybe a lot
of people will start to go broke and as
they do go broke they'll be forced to
curtail what they buy
in an economy driven largely by consumer
spending this is a very scary Trend when
people stop buying things the crash
comes
so you can see very clearly where this
is going everyone in Washington
understands exactly where it's going but
instead of taking real steps to fix it
like stop writing these massive spending
bills
they're taking everything they can all
the money's still on the table while
there still is money
Janet Yellen the Secretary of the
Treasury declared last week for example
that quote we must redouble our efforts
to decarbonize our economy
so what does that mean exactly how do
you decarbonize an economy well by
spending trillions of new stimulus
spending on renewable energy schemes
that by the way are owned by the Chinese
government and Democratic donors see how
that works you pass the cash around
while it still exists another name for
this is looting
it cannot go on forever by definition
because if the economy tanks everything
resets not just the economic questions
there could be genuine social and
political volatility our current
conversation can only happen in a
country that still believes itself to be
rich but once the country doesn't think
it's Rich Everything Changes
this tells you exactly why our leaders
seem so jumpy it's why they're more
determined than ever to move the
conversation away from economics no
talking about economics and toward
questions of race and obscure sexual
politics every new moral Panic they
create and they create them by the
dozens diverts attention away from
themselves they've been doing this for
quite a while since at least the
financial crisis since that time
2008-2009 our leaders have been telling
us over and over and over again many
books been written about it that the
central divide in America the seeping
wound the original sin is race
consider the timing at exactly the
moment the U.S government bailed out
Wall Street not a popular move use of
the terms race and racism in the
Washington Post in the New York Times
and USA Today jumped by more than 700
percent
so the official message was really clear
you've got problems and white men cause
those problems the white guys are taking
all the money and the perks of
themselves and they're holding everyone
else down now to this day you hear that
constantly including from Joe Biden it's
the most divisive possible message it's
also factually speaking a lie according
to Federal statistic white men aren't
even close to the richest group in the
United States Indian Americans Chinese
Americans Filipinos Koreans Indonesians
among others all have much higher median
household incomes than whites
so the story is not only destructive of
the social fabric it's not even true
the actual fault line in American life
is not color it's money
the real problem isn't racism it's
wealth distribution a small number of
people smaller every year have become
richer than anyone else in history
meanwhile the rest of the country is
stagnated and if you don't believe it
drive out 20 miles from the city center
and see how people are doing
so if the population understood this
that effectively it's an economic scam
it's got nothing to do with racism or
transgenders population should be pretty
mad about that
Joe Biden and his donors fear that they
don't want you to think about economics
they prefer to keep you Paralyzed by
guilt and shame and if that doesn't work
they'd rather be worried about Ukraine
Ukraine is the real Scandal or economic
problems are Putin's fault watch your
body
I'm doing everything within my power by
executive orders to bring down the price
and address the Putin Price height in
fact we've already made progress since
March inflation data was collected your
family budget your ability to fill up
your tank none of it should hinge on
whether a dictator declares war and
commits genocide in a half a world away
so this is their last desperate talking
point and it's highly familiar to anyone
who's watched American politics for the
last six years Putin did it
but it's ridiculous and we feel there's
always a moral obligation to rebutt it
with facts this chart clearly shows it
here are several core measures of
inflation that go back to 2011. you
notice that all of those measures begin
spiking in what year 2021 right after
Joe Biden took office it was the
spending that did it he's not the only
one who spent too much but he spent the
most
now Biden could claim the spike started
this February in the media would
probably protect him but things have
gotten so obvious economic decline being
the one thing you really can't hide
because people feel it every single day
if the media are beginning to stop
defending it watch this
the White House says those price jumps
are happening because of the war and
what they call quote Putin's price hike
but remember prices started spiking well
before the war in Ukraine began and
every time we talk about gas prices
Democrats do President Biden has always
Putin's price hike they're trying to
blame of course the Russian president
and the invasion of Ukraine uh for the
jump in prices but of course as polling
suggests that this President is going to
take a lot of the blame here Biden has
called it a Putin price hike but most
Americans aren't buying it despite what
President Biden says inflation was a
major concern way before Putin's
invasion
so no one's buying it because everyone
understands the most simple principle in
all economics which is supply and demand
if you create a lot more money the money
loses its value obviously and yet this
Administration proposes spending even
more money at a scale that this country
has never seen
the founder of FedEx Fred Smith summed
it up this way quote had we passed the
buildback better bill that Biden wanted
my guess is that we would be Weimar
Germany right now we'd have 25 percent
inflation rather nine or ten percent
that's all very obvious and again you
don't need to be
running the FED to understand it Joe
Biden may be the only person who doesn't
understand in this case he gets a pass
because in Joe Biden's head he's far
away he's somewhere else yesterday for
example Biden was fumbling through
questions about foreign policy when a
staffer in an Easter bunny costume
appeared out of nowhere and led him away
it's that bad now
how bad is it
here is Biden in one of the saddest
moments of his or any other presidency
this is from last week watch
there's not a single thing America can't
do when we do it together as the United
States of America
God bless you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shaking imaginary hands wandering off
into the great distance so the one thing
we can say was certainty about the White
House in the spring of 2022 is that Joe
Biden is not running it Joe Biden is
gone in his place are unelected audio
logs people who do not care what the
price of gas is they don't care if you
can afford dinner at Applebee's with
your kids they don't care even if war
with Russia could cause the destruction
of entire populations those things are
not interesting to them they care about
theories not reality so improving the
life of Americans elevating the American
population doesn't even rate on their
scale of concerns it's a pure
afterthought now we've known that for a
while they've been in charge for a while
and that's been
sustainable as long as everyone's
getting a check as long as everyone
feels like I've got enough money but the
second the economy turns South the
calculation changes completely
everything is different in a country
that believes it's becoming poor
the short-term effect
is a peaceful Revolt by voting so you
can be certain of this if there are free
and fair elections this November
neoliberalism will be swept away
entirely revealed as the joke it is
so the thing to worry about right now is
not public opinion public opinion is
settled nobody likes this the thing to
worry about right now is voting the
mechanics of voting if the public is
allowed to express its preference in the
midterms we're done but will they be
allowed that should be the thing people
are paying attention to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight